Чому варто берегти пам'ять про затоплені села?
Так само можна поставити питання:
«А чому варто берегти свою сім'ю?»
Я вважаю, що потрібно йти своїм шляхом.
Є культурна зброя, а є зброя,
яка реально стріляє.
Хтось може краще однією зброєю
користуватись, а хтось іншою.
Українці не використовують
до кінця культурну зброю.
Фіксувати те, що зараз, можливо,
зараз воно не так і цінно,
але воно буде потім ціннішим.
Спершу все починалось з велопрогулянок,
які потім переросли в велоекспедиції.
Доводилось самому подорожувати,
вивчати певну історію
Переяславщини та Лівобережної Київщини.
Було близько 40 000 кілометрів,
можливо трішки більше.
У пошуках якихось нових об'єктів:
це й цілющі джерела,
це й вікові дерева,
це й хати, які зараз відходять,
в якійсь унікальності,
які, якщо ти не вплинеш на ці процеси,
то вони можуть чи то зникнуть,
чи то призабутися.
Городище, Комарівка, Циблі,
під нами — село В'юнищі,
село Козинці затоплене.
Ще далі — Андруші́,
яке Шевченко «раєм» називав,
Трахтемирів, Монастирок, Зарубинці...
Це все ті села,
де людям примусово сказали:
«Переселяйтеся, тому що ці території
будуть затоплюватися».
У 1974-76 роках почалося наповнення водою
майбутнього на той час водосховища.
Лише в межах Переяславщини
на той час затопили десять сіл.
Основною публічною причиною була
необхідність підняття рівня води в Дніпрі
шляхом будівництва каскаду водосховищ,
гідроелектростанцій для того,
щоб виробляти електроенергію і щоб судна
проходили, не застрягаючи об дно.
Навіть якщо маску взяти
та подивитися на дно,
то серед піску можна побачити
упереміш рештки кераміки,
рештки цегли як підтвердження того,
що дійсно там вирувало життя свого часу,
але нині вирує життя морське
чи, правильніше, річкове.
2014 року народжується
громадська ініціатива «Корінь нації»,
яка займається пошуком
і збереженням цікавих об'єктів,
природних феноменів,
історично цікавих фактів,
які можливо навіть з різних причин
до цього часу не записані істориками.
І серед різних проєктів є спортивно-культорологічний
захід, як-от «Дніпро ревучий».
Команда співорганізаторів мала на меті популяризувати
історію затоплених сіл Переяславщини.
Ти не просто вже пропливаєш для себе,
а ти вже робиш якусь певну соціальну дію.
У цьому запливі навіть беруть участь ті,
хто жив у затоплених селах,
хоч вони мають уже не молодий
такий вік відносно.
Їм є що сказати.
Коли вони проходять цю дистанцію,
ти відчуваєш,
що це потрібна справа.
Канівське водосховище — це взагалі
наймолодше водосховище на Дніпрі.
І тому можна застати жителів,
які пам'ятають історію тих подій,
які відбувалися в межах цих територій,
що сьогодні під водою,
у межах тих сіл і околиць.
Мені було тринадцять років,
я був дуже радий,
що нас переселяють в нове село,
що тут буде газ, що тут буде перспектива,
що тут буде нова школа, нові друзі.
Ну я не можу вам передати,
яка це була радість.
Восени 1972 року, 5 листопада,
я йшов, сфотографував медпункт,
учителя Івасаленка Івана Ларіоновича,
Самійла Михайловича, клуб.
Для мого села ні в кого немає
таких останніх світлин.
Але коли я по світу поїздив, подивився...
2011 року ми з друзями поїхали на те місце,
де була школа
(вона уже була глибоко в воді).
Ми біля цієї школи метрів
на 400 зверху були.
І тут проходила якраз
вітрильна регата.
Я одразу ж скомандував,
ми сфотографувалися.
Останній кадр,
і в мене там підпис:
«Там, де було наше село,
там ходять кораблі».
І після цього нам так тяжко було!
І тільки тоді я зрозумів,
в якому раю я народився.
Добрий день!
Добрий день, а чому без охорони?
[жартує]
А це чий песик?
Певно що ваш?
Оце білий?
Так.
Так ви його беріть.
То це місцевий абориген.
Оце наша хата.
Оце комора, де я бігав.
Оце окіп називався.
А це баба Параска, батькова мати, жила.
Оце називалося окіп,
оце в мене тут дитинство [минуло].
Тобто оте дерево з бакланами, оце воно?
Оце воно тут ось.
Оце воно тут.
Оце окіп.
Тут Коліїва хата.
Я беру банку (джерела били),
беру, набираю води,
несу батькам на берег,
щоб можна було випити.
Така чиста вода була.
А по цьому джерелу я заганяв
і викидав в'юнів — ловив.
Ось така була природа.
Там був рай.
І всі свідомі люди мого віку
і старші дякують Богу,
що ми той рай побачили.
Безумовно, що матеріальні втрати від ГЕС великі,
не зважаючи на те, потрібна
вона чи не потрібна.
Але чомусь замовчуються духовні втрати.
Людей виселили з їхніх
рідних насиджених місць,
де складалися певні історичні умови,
і люди залишилися без батьківщини.
Пам'ять затоплена.
Родове коріння розірване.
Розумієте, у цьому питання.
Зараз ми доходимо до цікавого об'єкта,
це, по суті, пам'ятник затопленим селам України,
навіть так можна сказати.
Це є церква затопленого села Циблі.
Вона була на пагорбі, тому це єдина
архітектурна споруда, яка вціліла.
Деякі архітектурні споруди, які могли
виглядати з-під води, руйнували.
Але з різних причин ця церква залишилася.
Це вже основна частина храму,
поверх якого, як бачимо,
зараз гніздяться баклани.
Вони облюбували це місце.
Місцева громада шукає варіанти,
як відновити і зберегти хоча би цей храм.
У кожному селі був,
кожну стежинку пройшов.
І зараз мені сняться оці дороги.
І думаю: «Як же так, що в нас десять
населених пунктів пішли під воду?»
Затопили, і ніякої пам'яті
про них не залишилося.
Думаю, треба щось робити.
І потім почав шукати союзників, помічників.
Оце карта затоплених сіл Переяславщини.
Тут десять населених пунктів.
Ми собі поставили завдання
видати книжку про кожне з цих сіл,
щоб згадка була.
Ті люди, які не є прив'язаними
до свого коріння,
вони є метеликами, вони перелітають
з місця на місце, де є краще.
Із села люди від'їжджають.
Ну ця проблема ще не на стільки
велика, як та проблема,
що люди думками починають
від'їжджати з України,
шукаючи кращого добра десь.
Ти не можеш це змінити по всій Україні,
але ти частково можеш це
змінити якось тут.
Це не означає, що затоплені села
вплинуть на місцеве населення,
яке сьогодні є.
Але це означає, що якісь історичні
моменти, які там відбувались,
можуть вплинути на тих чи інших людей.
Створено, наприклад, маршрут
«Незвідана Переяславщина»,
створено маршрут «Україна-1187».
Такі напрацювання в форматі екскурсій
дозволятимуть не лише місцевим,
а й гостям дізнаватись
більше про Переяславщину,
дізнаватись більше про Україну.
І плюс — паралельно бачити чудові пейзажі,
які просто надихають, розслабляють,
дають можливість зрозуміти,
що ця чудова земля — це наша Україна.
Її потрібно зберігати,
її потрібно цінувати.
І потрібно зробити все, щоб ті діти,
які зараз під загрозою виїзду з України,
щоб вони тут лишились.